we got this one from timcast.com Biden
Administration sending 1 500 troops to
Southern border U.S officials are
expecting a surge of more than 35
000 migrants flooding through El Paso
after title 42 ends I guess my question
for these so-called writers at
timcast.com is are these illegal
immigrants they're expecting or just
general migrants because if it's like
people lining up at the border being
like hello I'd like to fill out forms to
peacefully into this country I don't
know if we need 1 500 troops this is the
most like actual action that you've seen
the Biden Administration take with you
know securing the Border as well so it's
interesting that they decided to do it
now right before election season I feel
like that might have something to do
with it well then
corrected for saying that it's 90 border
crossings are down 90 it's like all the
journalists because they're all already
here yeah that's right but but is it
what they're saying they're going to be
sending people back is that why they
need the troops I think it was just uh I
think they stopped Venezuelans if I
remember correctly it was Venezuela a
different country for a minute and there
was like a big a blockade and I think it
was in the same area as well outside of
El Paso where you just had like
Venezuelans piking tents and there was
thousands of them and then finally they
just allowed them to come in from one of
you want to know it was hilarious Lori
Lightfoot started complaining to Greg
Abbott about all of the immigrants that
have been sent up to Chicago that's the
least of your worries
the current sort of suburbs overnight
she did do that a while back yes she did
she sent them out to the the different
conservative Suburban areas but I love
how as soon as their ideology comes into
contact with reality they recognize okay
I have to either completely abandon my
principles or the thing I'm in charge of
is going to fail yeah I mean we've known
for a while that with the end of title
42 you would get different migrant
Caravans coming up and again I have no
reason to assume everyone is going to
attempt to cross illegally but just the
numbers bear out that many people will
attempt to cross illegally into the
country and without title 42 it becomes
much more difficult to expel illegal
immigrants uh we've already had a crisis
at Southern border for so long and the
Biden Administration has done nothing to
really address this I mean there have
been efforts to uh get majorcus removed
from office you know really remember
Kamal Harris is the is the board star
she's doing a great job so I think the
challenge is like as we go through an
era we wanted code regulations to end
and that was how we got title 42 but if
title 42 is coming to an end or if
covert regulations are coming down so
does title for it too so how do we
address the Border yeah well there was
an interesting question asked earlier
are these people coming legally or not
why is the military there I don't think
we're at any risk of not admitting
enough people into the United States at
this point I think we've had quite a bit
of immigration that was completely
undocumented totally illegal the
government had no oversight so this is
the least they can do yeah I mean it's
the least they can do it's not just the
southern border it's also all of the
Haitian and Cuban immigrants coming in
through Florida like their illegal
immigration is also up along Canada and
that's people flying from other
countries to Canada to enter the U.S I
mean this is an issue that we just for
whatever reason cannot man up and solve
well it's getting to the point too like
whenever I do border reporting or some
of my fellow journalists are down there
you're not encountering people from
Mexico anymore you're not encountering
people from those areas you're
encountering Cubans you're now it's
Chinese Nationals that are coming over
and in drove so we've gone to the point
of where all the Mexicans have already
came over right Mexico isn't really even
an immigration Point anymore yeah they
come up through it but it's Venezuelans
it's Cubans and every single like few
months I'll go down to the Border
whenever I have the chance different
kinds of migrants every single time it's
just evolving and more and more people
are coming over and so there's no need
for certain individuals to come over
because they're already here I mean do
you remember that story about there's
photos of uh Haitian migrants who were
collected under a bridge and that was
crazy and it was the famous photograph
of you know the border patrol agent on
uh whipping them condemned them and it
turned out that was completely a lie and
he has never done the media it wasn't
even and then after that the media ran
with it for like two months and then you
had the pictures being spread by all the
left wing uh you know publicist right
them whipping them and it's like that's
what was happening the most humane way
to control them so they don't die in
that River while they're crossing right
and all I bet if you ask anyone on the
street if they remembered this incident
they would all think it was someone from
Mexico crossing into the U.S and that's
just not it like people don't understand
the Border crisis because we've let it
get out of control and instead of
treating it like the Nash security and
humanitarian issue that it is right we
just say if you don't want people here
you must be bigoted and racist and bad
well and after that report went viral
too all of a sudden all of the migrants
were gone like the next two days they
all of a sudden were gone where do you
think they went they brought them into
our country well fundamentally right
there's two basic positions on this one
of which is completely new and would be
foreign to the thought of any pragmatic
or remotely reasonable political thinker
for all of history who wasn't trying to
destroy a country okay in the first
stream of thought the first
principle or whatever we want to call it
desire is
I think that the government should have
some oversight over who enters this
country in some control over who is
crossing over the Border because if we
don't have that there's literally no
purpose to having a board in the first
place the second stream of thought is
that's mean
and that's it there's no Counterpoint to
it there's no Counterpoint to it it's if
you think the government should
literally do anything of any kind of
immigration oversight at all it's
because you're racist
then you look at all the great Nations
that actually have low crime rates and
are actually succeeding with their
economies
they all have strong borders it's almost
like there's a correlation between a
real Nation an explanation weird the
thing you're not considering Sheamus is
that you know but what if you're mean
thing that you're not considering is
here's the cartoon of you farting lines
what did you just do how did you look at
that that's you that's literally what
you look like bro did you consider that
you made me look very thin that's well
you know thank you Sheamus you're
welcome
have a flattering caricature
yeah should we send this to somebody
you're gonna give away original art for
sure yeah we're gonna you gotta frame it
and put behind you now we send out
random uh knickknacks on the show to our
members
based yeah yes if you sign it and then
we can send it out
to a lucky guy it'd be funny that's a
really big jug of water next to me
that's what it that's the size of it
that's why you're so gassy is it water
what are you talking about we were
supposed to be talking about the merits
of being mean to migrants Sheamus but
you had to go and change the subject
well no you disagreed with me
you tried debating me you suggested I
was mean and so to prove you wrong I
showed you a picture I drew of you
farting with sync lines that's the
kindest thing he's ever done wow very
important news we just we discussed as
as as we were saying no I guess you are
just me right but that's that those are
those are literally the two options are
we happy with Joe Budden oh yeah
absolutely no I mean let me hold on let
me show you this picture of him I do
this other one I mean like this action
he's taking right now sending troops
down to the Border should we be like
that's a good thing please do it more I
think it's a start yeah but that's it
it's just a start it's something that
should have happened right as he got in
office he shouldn't have repealed any of
the immigration plans that Trump had
because they were working and now that
he's doing that he's got a back pedal
because even normal Americans are
starting to see okay this is kind of
weird that we're allowing anybody and
everybody through so I think this is
their way of almost compensating right
before election seizing saying hey we
understand your problems conservatives
not you Maga terrorists though because
we don't like you guys but General
conservatives and progressives we know
you want to secure border so this is our
way of giving it to you I think it's
just to buy election points do you
remember his first state of the union
address where he just started
appropriating Trump's talking points he
did said that we need to secure the
Border I mean when your agenda involves
capitalism and he's our capitalism we're
good man defend the police don't defund
him he did well he did say that he
literally said those words except he it
was less articulate than that and more
that's my favorite narrative speaking
like in Congress you know clips of him
on any kind of committee over his very
long when he was capable it's crazy I
just hope that it sounds like this look
if we're going to have a new policy here
you got to listen up we got to have
better taxes we gotta we gotta have
lower taxes in this country and now he's
like the pressure and the slurring and
like getting lost it's rough I I think
the problem with this action I I won't
say problem I think it's good the Border
needs more support especially all the
agents there
it's just that they created a problem
because they tried to walk back all of
Trump's immigration like any kind of
thing that could help stop this crisis
because again remember people migrating
here go through terrible things like it
is not the worst thing it is not an
acceptable thing to put anyone through
it's not good for America it's not good
through the women and children and men
who go through it so why we would
support it I don't understand I think
it's a it's it's okay but like you're
saying it feels like cheap cheap uh
points before the election and
you know if he gets enough pushback I'm
sure they'll pull the troops back well
and the thing is they are not really
committed to solving this problem of
course they never will be well and with
the troops too is like we saw this down
at like Eagle Pass and other points that
are really hot right now is whenever I
go down there if you do have National
Guard troops you do have any of these
troops they quite literally all their
job is to do is to facilitate the
migrants crossing so they're just
helping them cross they're not stopping
them they have absolutely no power
they're still under akin to border
patrol and and when I was down there
last time at Eagle Pass they were quite
literally intentionally pulling their
Humvees up in front of these migrants so
I couldn't do my job and take videos of
the processing so it's like where is
this gonna go it's gonna go absolutely
nowhere they have no authority to engage
with cartels I've heard horror stories
of them watching literally people shoot
children across just across the river
they can't do anything the child crawls
over and then they give the kid Aid or
you know they're they're dumping people
into Vats of acid these cartels and
facilitating all these migrant Caravans
that are coming over right but the
National Guard can't do anything so what
are they there for it's worthless I mean
think was it DeSantis who said like he
answered the policy of like if you
arrive on a boat we will turn you away
you can't and it's it's to deter people
from taking an extremely dangerous
journey to try and illegally enter the
country it's sad because then it forces
as well there's a downside for them to
be facilitated through the cartels and
that's when the worst possible things
actually happen to him that's when you
get the rape trees that's when you get
the murders that's when you get the
torture is when these cartels are put in
charge they're multi-billion dollar
industries that are I would argue more
powerful than a lot of a more powerful
than a lot of world governments and
you're giving them more power exactly I
think about when I was uh going to
college and I went to school in Texas uh
they were talking about someone who
volunteered with I can't remember the
name of the organization but they
basically are like oh we go to the
Border we hand out water bottles and we
try people probably one of those
Catholic organizations that facilitate
I'm not going to run into the Catholic
conversation you better not but I will
Shia LaBeouf was there oh yes she says
do it why why can't why can't he be
sincere I hope he is but okay you know
let's see I haven't heard about it since
the thing is is like any of these
organizations you are actually
encouraging people to risk their lives
to do something dangerous and illegal
that we know ultimately harms everyone
involved I think this is the craziest
thing that we hear out of the left that
we should not build a border wall
because it's what no humans illegal like
I just don't understand why would you
want to put people in the positions that
they are in other criminals they're
criminal immigrants exactly I don't I
don't like they are breaking news no I
don't like the phrase illegal immigrants
no human is I'm like what is it what
does it even mean illegal immigrant like
the person's another criminal immigrants
yeah I mean that that term would make
more sense but now I mean whether
criminal immigrants or anything they're
committing crimes when Crossing into the
country but there is no such thing as a
legal process or an illegal process
anymore you can be a god away you can
come and get your papers for the border
patrol and then they'll just release you
so anyone can come through I mean
terrorists quite literally anybody can
enter our country and we're not doing it
I've known people who uh grew up in
Eastern Europe who are advised you know
it's actually it's actually more likely
that if you enter illegally through the
southern border you are you are more
likely to be able to stay in America
than if you go through the application I
saw Luke out here probably uh no I just
feel like that's the most sickening
thing it's a similar and I this is a
broad comparison to draw but uh the
conversations we have about gun
ownership right like if you ban guns
only law-abiding people suffer people
who do not care about your laws don't
care about your laws they're not going
to uh register their guns or give you
the guns or do anything you ask them to
do it's only the people who believe in
Law and Order and want to positively you
know constructively follow the law I
thought it was funny the last time I was
down at the border because I went into
Mexico and coming back in I had the idea
I was like I wonder if I drop my ID or
give my ID to one of these other
reporters I'm with and cross the Rio
Grande because I've done it before and
get process as an illegal immigrant act
like I don't speak English like what
would the process look like I was going
to I probably have the plan to it's a
felony but but that's the only that was
the only downside
you're gonna charge me put another I
came through the legal way and then I
got detained for over six hours because
I was on this terrorist watch list for
my reporting on January 6th and then
they treated me worse than the actual
illegal immigrants that are coming
through I'm like I'm an American citizen
and you have people walking across the
river and then being released into
America in less time that's the gulaga
uh uh
yeah saying that uh for criminals it's
just their nature what can you do yes
but for you you knew you knew better yep
yeah you're a bad man that's exactly it
right we have to go after the people
whenever someone commits a crime it's
because of their socio-economic
environment the way that they were
raised they would not have ever done
anything wrong they're just stealing
bread exactly and then when you do
something wrong it's just because you're
evil and bad and you're despicable
disgusting Enemy of the State well we
got speaking of doing things bad uh in a
very childish move Tim tried to edit my
drawing of him it's not nearly as good
he put me in the background sniffing the
fart I found I think it's really
immature and he's saying um Parts yeah
which I have which I do we will say if
if I smell a good one sometimes I feel
like I'm in a fifth grade but I never
smell a good one Bazinga yeah that's
right this is I can we just appreciate
that my Art's been ruined ruined it's
been vastly it's been ruined I wonder if
that you can even say are you able to
see this can you launch a poll did this
did this ruin Sheamus is just standing
there going farts you just I would say
it's like you destroyed something
Picasso made but Picasso didn't really
make all that much that was good
remember remember that story about
Salvador Dali he like bought dinner at a
restaurant and then he drew a doodle and
a napkin signed it and paid for his meal
with that and they were like I thought
there was a story
like me something and he does and he's
like okay pay me a thousand dollars
she's like what but I thought you were
just doing it for free and he's like no
this is my craft it's taken me a long
time oh yeah they said you did that in
10 seconds and he said no it took me
years to learn how to do it it's like
then why did you do it so badly Picasso
he was very talented he was really good
at and he started doing this abstract
garbage yeah like his original paintings
were really good and then he just
started making trash and everyone went
that's so good because he's portraying
the world other than it actually is and
I don't want to see the world as it is
because that makes it more difficult for
me to live a vicious life I feel like
you sound like his disappointed parents
we sent you to art school for this you
had so much promise first of all if you
went to Art School his parents were
already disappointed thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time